hallo freunde und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge micro effects heute
am freitag hier auf meinen kanal wo ich
euch im mai kräftig special die ihm per
mail an contact at gmail.com senden
können und in den posteingang sind immer
noch weit über 7000 mails mit
irgendwelchen fakten und ich habe mir
jetzt ein paar rausgesucht und wollt ihr
euch vorstellen falls ihr auch
irgendwelche facts haben die ihr mir zu
sein wollt könnt ihr das natürlich auch
wieder per mail machen und ich würd
sagen kann neben den text hat wieder ein
paar coole wirksam starten wie ich wird
es freuen wenn die bis zum ende dran
bleiben würde und dann fällt endlich mal
an
dazu muss ich heute allerdings sagen
dass ich die ganzen effekt sich heute
habe ich alle aus dem minecraft die
kinos genommen und zwar wurden wir per
mail zwar ein paar coole sachen
zugesendet allerdings haben viele davon
nicht geklappt oder waren irgendwie nur
command und so deswegen da warte ich
immer noch auf die perfekten effekt
sieht man echten vorstellen kann die
auch nicht wie schon andere videos
vorgekommen sind deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich nehme ein paar fakten
einfach aus dem minecraft wiki wo ich
weiß okay das klappt wenn das in dem
wiki da drin steht deswegen gehe ich
erstmal hier in den game 0 also dass ich
mit survival modus bilden und die kennt
das ja wenn ich einem zombies potter
dann greift nämlich an wenn ich jetzt
allerdings mit inventar bin greift er
mich an und wenn ich dann irgendwann
sterben liege ich auch im inventar so
rum als die kinder seien getötet wird
und dann fällt man hin und dann liegt da
diese leiche so quasi mehr oder weniger
auf dem boden verschwindet im inventar
ist allerdings noch und ich kann diese
leiche quasi sogar im inventar noch
steuern als wenn ich ganz normal da wäre
also das ist ein bisschen perplex und
ein bisschen paradox das ganze
funktioniert ich hab ich auch die
fachbegriffe weltmeister und ja das ist
auf jeden fall fällt nummer eins und
wenn ich jetzt als cache drücke bin ich
in diesem menü du bist gestorben wenn
ich jetzt drücken die ganze inventar
wird geht es nicht sondern meines neuem
inventar ein mann gestorben ist wenn man
wirklich schon vor dem tod im inventar
ist ich habe verstanden was ich sagen
wollte und machen weiter mit dem zweiten
fed die zweite sache ist auch recht
simpel und zwar sind es heute echt alles
so ein bisschen so mehr oder weniger
effects die eigentlich wirklich hab mal
eine minute redezeit effekt ist halt so
ein bisschen so als ich sagen euch
einfach mal zu ihr habt ja jetzt noch
mal einen kompass und er zeigt ja immer
im norden oder in diese richtung wo ihr
halt hin läuft also wenn die roten
1 zeigt könnt ihr bei f3 sehen okay das
ist die und die richtung norden süden
westen blabla et cetera china eher links
am rand
wenn ich allerdings im creative modus
bin hat man hier den kompass der bei der
suche stehen dieser bewegt sich
ebenfalls mit der geht auch in die
richtung wo man gerade hinguckt das
heißt der kompass ist immer auch dahin
wo man hinguckt das heißt rein
theoretisch so was euch der fed
eventuell bringen könnte ohne dass er
jetzt einfach wisst ist halt einfach
dass der kompass im creative immer dahin
zeigt und wenn ihr im creative suite und
ihr braucht kompass könnt ihr auch
einfach da oben hingucken und euch dahin
drehen dass da an orten ist dann wisst
ihr das neue müsst euch nix an compass
holen das ist auf jeden fall auch eine
ganz witzige interessante sache zu
wissen und das perfekte 24 ist fake
nummer drei und ich weiß echt nicht was
jemand mit meinem araber gute kommt halt
auch aus minecraft wickie und zwar ist
hier ein klebriger kolben ich kann
einfach mal klebriger kolben hier in
diesem kessel ryan stelle wenn ich mich
hier einfach mal den schalter drücke bin
ich quasi im kessel nicht mehr drin weil
ich dann quasi der ausbau und zwar wenn
ihr das jetzt mal so sehe der 50 tage
quasi aus diesen kesselhaus das sieht
auch wenn ich jetzt hier mal so
reingehen und jetzt drücke dann packe
ich da einfach raus finde ich ein
bisschen komisch weil dieser kessel ist
eigentlich ein sehr stabiles material
sag ich mal also der wird ja aus stahl
hergestellt und so weiter und so fort
das ding jetzt eigentlich recht stabil
und man sollte eigentlich mit geschoben
werden die insm hat finde ich oder wie
in seinem boot oder sogar und hier packt
man halt einfach raus und wenn man das
an den klebrigen kolben packt das ist
ein bisschen eine traurige sache effekt
kommt ebenfalls aus dem minecraft forum
und zwar haben wir hier schon wieder
einen kessel stehen und die sache ist
halt einfach wenn ich jetzt mal hoch
fliegen und dann voll drauf schieße
bleibt der pfeil auf diesem blog leben
also man sieht quasi dass der kessel
quasi von dem pfeil oder von
schneebällen et cetera die fallen nicht
direkt am rhein sondern bleibt quasi
oben drauf liegen und das ganze ist halt
irgendwie ein bisschen komisch
beispielsweise in altenrhein schweiz hat
das ganze auch nicht so richtig also mit
dem kessel
diese ganze trivial oder weniger als ein
bisschen komisch auch wenn das wasser
drin ist in dem kessel bleibt dieser
teil immer noch darauf stecken also das
ist alles ein bisschen komisch hat mit
diesem kessel so los ist wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal so einfach drauf
schießt auf dieses wasser lädt der
vergleich nicht durch das wasser durch
nach unten sondern er bleibt quasi
darauf kleben
das ist ein bisschen komisch allerdings
ist das halt einfach so muss man so
hinnehmen
denk damit kann man eigentlich ganz gut
leben
wo normalerweise erwartet ihr jetzt den
fünften effekt allerdings ist es so dass
ich heute mal gesagt hat anstatt den
fünf effekt nämlich jetzt einfach mal
etwas dran wo ich einfach mal selber ein
bisschen drüber reden wollte und zwar
steht diese serie in letzter zeit das
habe ich ja schon mal gesagt ein
bisschen immer in der kritik weil es
halt immer so war es ist halt einfach so
dass in letzter zeit viele kommentare
kommen in die richtung 8 defektes kacke
und auch da immer mal besser informieren
können und auch das wird doch da schon
vorgestellt und hey der hat das doch von
da und da irgendwie und der effekt ist
aber blöd und das funktioniert gar nicht
und das liegt an der unterseite leute
die sich über alles aufregen können und
in allem irgendwie irgendwas finden wo
sie irgendwas kritisieren können ich
verstehe das nicht also an alle leute
die eventuell irrt schon wieder handel
schweiz kommt dankeschön und eventuell
noch dran sind dann schaut euch die
serie doch einfach nicht an
das wäre einmal eine opportunity
durchfeuchtete und die andere partie
wäre eine andere möglichkeit wäre
einfach dass ihr mir eventuell auch mal
perfekt zu sein weil sich zehnmal so
viele kommentare perfekt ist kacke der
interessiert mich nicht
und da denke ich mir mal so ok es in
fact is in fact rein theoretisch könnte
ich sagen mit der linken maustaste mache
ich einen blog abo drei theoretisch
könnte ich das sagen diesen fans halt
einfach so ich stelle die sachen vor die
ich finde die gut passen die ich noch
nicht kenne und wenn ihr denkt okay das
defekte nicht so geil da gibt es viel
bessere dann könnt ihr die mir einfach
mal per mail zu senden kräftig email ort
kommt und ich meine dann sind wir quasi
alle in rot und defektem zugesendet
werden ich kann ja auch nicht alle
folgen von allen amerikanischen anderen
youtube angucken wo irgendetwas
vorgestellt wird in minecraft ich kann
ja nicht alles wissen über die komplette
szene deswegen das ist ein bisschen
komisch da immer ich versuche damals
nämlich ganz cool sind ich denke das
gelingt noch meistens weil die bewertung
der immer ganz gute noch ein paar leute
merkt man halt immer so acht es aber
kacke und du bist du blöd und du bist
aber herzlich und die aber zum friseur
und weiter sehe ich würd sagen das war's
dann auch schon mit der heutigen folge
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn es
das getan hat dann zeigen damit einmal
werte unter uns in der nächsten folge am
dienstag wieder auf wiedersehen